time then to put your questions to our
experts panel laura suter is head of
personal finance at aj bell the
investment platform and nina scaro chief
executive at the center for economics
and business research good to see you
both we're also joined tonight by sumi
rabindra kumar head of policy and
research at the trestle trust which runs
across a network of food banks across
the country ladies it's very good to see
you tonight thank you uh for your time
today i suppose we start with the
questions and that's what we're here for
isn't it um first question comes from
twitter uh the prime minister says that
jobs are the answer to the cost of
living crisis
what about those in low-paid in secure
jobs i suppose uh question for you
perhaps laura to start things off yeah
so part of the logic behind that is that
we have very low unemployment at the
moment and so that means
that there's a bit of a war for talent
out there and so wages should rise
accordingly um but as this person points
out that's not very good for people that
are on lower paid jobs or just don't
have the ability to move jobs i think
the government's other solution is
people upskilling but clearly that takes
time it takes time for people to learn a
new industry or a new job so that's not
an overnight solution for people
struggling with their energy bills now
and nina maybe i can just ask you that
this really has come out of nowhere and
people do seem to need help now not any
later don't they
they absolutely do and especially
keeping in mind that for some households
they already had a couple of challenging
years with covid and now they're
entering this new this new cost of
living crisis right on the the back of
that and in fact i i wouldn't be
surprised despite the the current
rhetoric from the government if we did
see some targeted support in not too
long because i think we're going to get
to a point where the government really
doesn't have a have a choice but to to
recognize it more than more assistance
is needed urgently well we'll come to
perhaps what some of those solutions
might be a tail end of this question
most people using food banks
already have uh jobs a point for you
there sumi
yeah certainly in the uk food bank need
is a really stark reflection but for
many work alone isn't going to be the
solution
um we see some people in work we also
see quite a few people so up to about a
third who've had difficult um work
experiences and are now between jobs
because of the insecurity in the labour
market
and then finally just to point out that
actually the really over-represented
groups who come to food banks in our
network and are people who can't work or
face barriers to work
um
so that's for example disabled people 62
percent of people referred um a disabled
that's three times the rate in the
general population
um so you know we need to face the
reality that jobs are not going to going
to be the solution for everyone
particularly if you're talking about
tackling food bank need
um and we shouldn't be cutting whole
groups of people adrift by ignoring that
fact
all right um let's uh hear from jim my
one job isn't enough jim says with the
cost of living crisis do i get
a second job it's a fair question isn't
it laura should he
yeah i think a lot of people will be
facing this i think if your income isn't
enough to meet the rising cost of living
and the bills that you've got going out
you have two options you either need to
increase your income or you need to
reduce the cost of your bills and you
can do a bit of both but if taking on a
second job is an option and it's
something that you have available to you
then that can be one way of balancing
the books obviously for lots of people
it may not be possible to take on those
additional hours or to take on a whole
extra job yes nina for some
might be an answer to some but it's
perhaps more difficult
in practice for many
yes i do imagine that that some are
already working full hours at a job that
despite working full hours isn't paying
them enough to
to face the the very stark and you know
very rapidly arriving costs of cost of
living rises and what i think is a
particular worry is that given what
we're hearing now i feel i fear that
things will get worse before they get
they get better in terms of the the
energy prices which also trickle down
onto prices of other services and goods
i think things are going to get uh to
get significantly worse in the coming
months so people that are already facing
problems are probably in for for quite a
difficult period and sumi what are
people telling you when they come to to
food banks are they feeling they have to
get additional employment if they can
perhaps most very difficult for a lot of
people though
of course as we were just saying there
are lots of groups of people who come to
food banks um people who are most at
risk are people who can't take on those
additional hours often because they're
doing unpaid work like caring for family
members or because they have a
disability or mental health problems and
so that option is really restricted
restricted for quite a few people and
that's why we see people coming to food
banks because they don't have those
other options available to them and they
also don't have the security of
a life a sort of adequate lifeline from
the benefit system
okay let's move on roli says it's clear
to see that many households are facing
significant cost of living crises and
this is going to result in people losing
their houses and jobs why can't the
government see this
and act now perhaps uh you can address
this for us nina yes i would say as i
was saying a moment ago i actually do
would expect the government to come out
with some targeted targeted um reliefs
in not too long um we were expecting if
we think back to the to the spring
statement we were actually expecting
some more targeted relief to already be
announced at that point and that was
certainly before the situation got as
bad as it is now i wouldn't be surprised
at all if in the coming weeks we saw um
some sort of additional one-off
assistance offered to people perhaps um
receiving universal credit um or some
sort of an um assistance to people who
who normally receive the the warm homes
um discount um so i think some sort of
targeted assistance rather than
something very broad brush like uh v8
cut would be most appropriate at this
point and laura is that the way forward
something targeted we know we had the
queen speech just the other day much was
made that hardly anything was announced
then to tackle the cost of living crisis
much debate in the commons afterwards
that something did need to be done it
does seem the government is moving in
that direction to do something but is
that the correct course of action and
will it help now which is what people
are really asking yeah so i think the
government has announced some targeted
support specifically energy bills um
we've had the kind of energy loan scheme
that will kick in later this year and
council tax rebate of 150 pound for a
lot of households and i think it's that
kind of support that we're probably
going to see more of i think later in
the year we have the autumn statement
which is another kind of mini budget
but also in october we have the next
energy price cap change and that's when
we're all going to see our energy bills
go up by even more and i think at that
point that might be when the government
is waiting to make more announcements
about targeted support particularly for
energy bills but like you alluded to
there for lots of families by that point
they're already going to have had to
have taken on debt to pay their bills um
and they're already gonna have faced a
lot of financial hardship if we don't
get any help before then well stay with
us because that leads us to our next
question keith says i'm pensioner and i
cannot claim pension credit i already
shop for all the bargain buyers and i
know how to cook but still i cannot
afford my electricity what am i supposed
to do many people will indeed be asking
that tonight i think so and i think he
sums up one of the big issues that we've
seen so far which is that pensioners
have been left out in the cold a bit so
what we saw is the amount that the state
pension increased by was changed this
year and so it didn't rise by as much as
it could have done and the increase that
it's seen now looks tiny in comparison
to the inflation rates that we're seeing
at the moment and no specific support
has been targeted at pensioners and
particularly those that live just on the
state pension um so i think lots of
pensioners are feeling like they would
have expected more support in the spring
statement that we talked about earlier
and we might see more of that help one
thing that i would say is that if people
are really struggling there's lots of
help out there that people might not
necessarily know that they're eligible
for so the government has filtered down
some funding to local councils that
people can go and apply for so this is
kind of help that you need to apply for
rather than an automatic rebate like we
saw with the council tax um or it's
worth going to an organization like
citizens advice where they'll be able to
look at your income your outgoings and
see if there's any additional benefits
or support that you might be eligible to
because so many benefits out there are
under claimed and people could be
getting more money and then let me put
this to you linked to to pensions peter
asked what about people living on a
state pension 350 pounds doesn't even
touch the size opportunity for two
people tax cuts don't help us and the
extra council fund cannot help uh with
income and it has to be said of course
that people are getting a council tax
rebate well not everybody but
many households
but to fund the electricity the hikes in
energy prices this is a loan and it does
have to be paid back
yes or at least that is what is
structured at at the moment again i if
the situation continues to to worsen
it's not i know it hasn't been announced
yet but i wouldn't be entirely shocked
if what is now being sort of you know
discussed as a loan ends up being
converted to to a grand down the the
line we've seen similar changes in the
in the past
um perhaps uh for example for some of
the the covid covid relief so we've seen
that the sort of assistance offered can
be quite quite fluid okay well do stay
with us thank you for all your comments
and thoughts for now uh you are watching
to remind you a special question and
answer program on the cost of living
crisis here on sky news and next we'll
be asking why are people on disability
benefits being ignored see in a couple
minutes
hello welcome back to sky news tonight
this is a special question and answer
program on the cost of living crisis
joining us our guest laura suter head of
personal finance at the investment
platform aj bell nina scarole chief
executive at the center for economics
and business research and sumi rabindra
kumar had a policy in research at the
trussell trust which runs food banks
thanks for staying with us let us move
on with these questions anil asks a
question while price is increasing at
higher rates than inflation this is
going to make inflation worse rising
interest rates will mean people will
have even less money to buy essentials
and that will cause the cost of living
crisis uh to get worse nina let me put
that
to you
no end in sight to any of this it seems
right i think i think there are two
quite distinct parts to that question so
first on one on why are prices rising
higher than the rate of inflation so
the way the rate of inflation is
calculated is based on a on a survey
where people say how much of their
overall expenditure they spend on
particular goods and services and then
based on those answers you weigh up how
much of significance how much of a wage
to give to each product and service you
put in what is called the the consumer
basket of goods put in this basket so
it's really yeah so it's really a
weighted average there are questions of
is what we're putting in that you know
metaphorical basket correct are things
weighted correctly so it's it's very
much a weighted average so it's entirely
possible that depending on your own
consumption patterns you could be facing
price increases faster than what the
typical consumer is is facing and i
often feel this way myself i've been
saying for a while i feel like my own
inflation rate is probably close at 20
25
you know well twice over the the other
part of the question was relating to
interest rates
um and it's entirely correct to point
out that it's quite unusual to have a
situation where the economy is
slowing sharply yet interest rates are
rising and it's a very unusual and an
unenviable situation for the bank of
england to to be in it's partially
because they're trying to control
inflationary pressures some of which are
still lingering from sort of demand
driven inflation earlier in 2021 and is
now being compounded by the russia
ukraine situation and supply chain
issues um but yeah to i i do see the
need to to raise interest rates to help
on the inflationary side and the way
that that helps is by higher interest
rates mean that there is less money
available
which controls the amount of demand
there is and controls price levels but
it's entirely correct to point out that
it's quite counterintuitive to being
doing that when economy is already
slowing yeah we see the interest rates
are going up let me put that to sue me
the uh the fact
inflation people facing rising costs
that's something that people must be
telling you as they as they come to food
banks it seems everything
the cost of everything to many is going
up
absolutely we've done polling and that
shows that people are really struggling
with the just the bare essentials
um like clothing toiletries food right
across the board
and actually it's a combination of those
things so it's not just struggling with
one bill it's the fact that it's
multiple bills that are piling up and
people are having to choose which
essentials they go without
or sort of how much debt they're pulled
into because they can't afford these um
spiraling costs and it's really
reflected in the level of need that
we're seeing in
our network of food banks at the moment
which has been accelerating exactly
since this cost of living crisis first
emerged in the autumn and we think that
it's a you know set to get worse um
given the direction of travel of um
inflation rates i'll come back to you in
a moment ask about cookery lessons for
now though ian says my power is supplied
by a nuclear power station a solar farm
and one of the biggest offshore wind
farms in europe why has the price of my
electricity uh gone up perhaps uh one of
you nina what uh how can you answer that
well based on the energy strategy we've
heard about recently from the government
it seems like their thinking is similar
to to ian's in the sense that they're
thinking if we can reduce our foreign
energy dependence and boost the sources
of energy that ian has listed there
solar
solar wind nuclear we won't the country
won't be as susceptible to to future
shocks but as we've heard from the
strategy that is really not going to do
anything with this crisis you know in
their time frame is sort of
20 30 and and beyond and the reality is
at the moment the uk like much of europe
is still dependent on energy imports and
even if we are getting less of our
energy than some european countries
directly from russia it doesn't mean
it's isolated from these global shocks
because
the the
sort the markets that the uk does source
its imports from are raising their
prices in recognition of the lowered
overall available supply because of the
russia ukraine situation all right we'll
come back to that in a moment and calls
for a windfall tax i know that's
something we need to discuss a question
for sumi this from margot i had cookery
lessons at school now uh children don't
simple recipe leaflets would help do
food banks offer fresh food uh that
question of course in relation to the
conservative mp lee anderson didn't he
claim that people who use food banks
don't know how to cook or manage their
finances properly can't cook can't
budget effectively what he had to say
in answer to some of the question here
around sort of fresh food certainly some
food banks and do offer fresh food if
they can
and they have local partnerships that
allow them to do that
but really the point here is you know
that reflects the fact that food banks
will always do whatever they can to step
up and help their community as much as
they can but really it shouldn't be left
to
frontline organizations like food banks
to ensure that people can put food on
the table
um and the stark reality is that people
simply don't have enough
just don't have enough income
to be able to um put food on table and
afford the essentials our research shows
that the average income of someone
referred to a food bank in our network
was about 57 pounds a week and that's
simply not enough to stretch um across
all the essential bills that we all need
to
pay you know keep a roof over our heads
food on the table and so on
and so what this comes down to is food
bank need is really about lack of income
it's not about food it's not about
cooking
and that's the stark reality that people
are facing
and that's exactly why
karking back to your question about sort
of inflation rates why we are focusing
so much on the fact that urgent action
needs to be taken and to strengthen our
social security system so people have
that um lifeline to be able to afford
those essentials um and in particular at
the moment bring benefit rates um in
line with the inflation that we're
seeing at the moment and because
otherwise people are left without
options
and really what they're telling us there
are no more cutbacks to make let's talk
about benefits a question from pamela
why are people on disability benefits
specifically being ignored no uplift
pamela says during the pandemic the warm
home payment is about to be reduced by
300 000 people a question for laura is
that correct what pamela said there um
so it is and it isn't so um the warm
home discount scheme is being
restructured by the government and it's
been targeted at people on means-tested
benefits
it means that an extra three-quarters of
a million people will be eligible for it
and actually the amount is increasing so
previously it was 140 pounds towards
your energy bills now it's 150 pounds
however part of that change means that
lots of people on disability benefits
are no longer going to be eligible for
it so that's where that 300 000 figure
comes from and so
it means that lots of those people are
going to be left without that money and
still paying high energy costs and it's
worth pointing out as well that disabled
people generally face higher energy
costs either through being in the home
more or having specialist medical
equipment that they need that needs
power
or for instance needing to wash their
clothes more there are lots of reasons
why they would have higher energy needs
but also benefits haven't increased by
the rate of inflation and so their
income isn't rising to match that
very interesting all right thank you
again for now do stay with us you're
watching a special question and answer
program on cost of living crisis next
we'll be asking if fuel companies are
making record profits why are we still
paying such high fuel costs back up
so then let's answer some more of your
questions with our expert panel joining
us tonight laura suter head of personal
finance at aj bell the investment
platform nina scaro is chief executive
at the center for economics and business
research good to see you and sumi
rabindra kumar head of policy and
research at the trussel trust which of
course runs a network of food banks
across the country uh great to see you
all right let's uh crack on with our
questions then raj asks with the rising
cost of living and economy shrinking is
it time for the chancellor to take a
radical step before the uk ends up in
recession um nina one for you much
speculation that we are going to enter a
recession sometime
this year the chancellor says he's
looking at various measures in what we
just saw there but he really does need
to take some concrete action doesn't he
the the chancellor is in a rather
unenviable position because he is
actually in a place of uh you know
coming off of a couple of years of
quite loose fiscal policy so basically
being very generous with public spending
in light of the covet pandemic so just
as the time has come for him to
basically raise government's revenues
via via taxes and to consider where he
can cut government spending he is now
being called upon to
to actually help bolster the economy in
terms of what we're expecting to see
from the chancellor again i would expect
to see some targeted support for the
poorest households i certainly wouldn't
hold my breath for a expansive
package of government fiscal support
again because of where their thinking is
in terms of just having had uh two years
of quite a lot of spending and the
feeling that that needs to to come under
control
uh laura
he put this furlough scheme in place
some would see this is fairly rapid but
here we are with a cost of living crisis
that's only going to get worse in
the next few months people will ask why
can't you do anything right now
yeah and i think people have maybe
because of the pandemic they've got used
to the government acting relatively
quickly and that was the phrase
unprecedented time has been used a lot
but that was an unprecedented time and
as nina pointed to we've now rolled into
another slightly unprecedented time
i think that the government is trying to
have a balancing act between not
spending too much government money at a
time when it's already racked up a lot
of debt through the pandemic but also
trying to help people out where it can
and so i agree that i think we'll see
more specific helpful things like energy
bills
or more council tax rebates kind of
expansions of those schemes that we've
already seen rather than any radical
massive announcement of government
spending at this point and simi just
briefly tell me two key things that you
would like the chancellor to do now to
help the cost of living crisis
well we know that people can't afford to
wait much longer they're already facing
these impossible decisions around um you
know their their living standards
and what we really want to see is that
targeted support for people on the very
lowest incomes who actually you know to
date in terms of the support packages
that have been announced in response to
the crisis
have really been piecemeal they haven't
been targeted on people on the lowest
incomes they don't reach people quickly
enough and they don't go far enough
and we have a system that is
specifically designed in four
circumstances like this that targets um
support quickly and efficiently to those
who need it most and that's the social
security system so what we want to see
is investment in that system and
particularly as an urgent step bringing
payments in line with the information
seeing at the moment it's quite
interesting that both the chancellor and
the prime minister has talked about the
steps that they took during the pandemic
as examples of their compassion and
their speedy response and yet the
glaring gap in the current cost of
living crisis and support that has been
announced so far is precisely that
investment in social security that we
saw during the pandemic like the uplift
um 20 mile uplift a week to universal
credit that is missing
and that needs to be rectified all right
let's crack on the chancellor mike asks
uh took 5p off fuel tax but how does
that help people who can't afford a car
in fact his transport costs go up we
have to pay more to use public transport
therefore making us worse off would it
not have been better to cut vat so
everyone gained not just the better off
uh perhaps i can put that to you laura
yeah i mean i entirely agree i think
that the 5p cut to the fuel duty for one
didn't go anywhere near contract in the
price increases that we'd already seen
but also you've got to be at a certain
wealth level to be able to afford a car
and lots of people
as mike was saying
can't afford a car and so they're using
public transport and we've seen massive
increases in train fares for example um
so i think what people would rather see
rather than perhaps some headline
grabbing news around fuel getting
cheaper is actually much more targeted
support at low-income families who are
really struggling at the moment who
couldn't even think about buying a car
and putting petrol in it because that
would be so far beyond their budget at
the moment all right andy says
successive governments have kicked the
can of long-term secure affordable power
supply down the road for decades why
doesn't the government consider
nationalizing all utility companies
electricity gas and water is that
something you might be able to comment
on you know well we have seen other
european countries considering um
options such as nationalization of
utility providers it hasn't been with uh
much uh you know seriousness discussed
recently in the in the uk
we certainly didn't get any indication
of that happening from the government's
energy strategy that was discussed
recently i would say that even though
the sort of green agenda and energy
security has been talked about for a
long time i do think the next few years
are going to see more of a serious focus
on the
on the topic partially because of the
russia ukraine situation because no
matter what happens with the war from
here on out even if the war ended
tomorrow nobody is going to want to be
dependent on russian exports for many
decades ahead so i think despite the
economic downturn there is going to be
continued pressure for the government to
and private companies to continue
investing in in domestic energy supplies
um so i would expect to see more of that
in terms of where the government is
thinking the solution lies all right
john says can you please address why the
record profits for fuel companies like
bp are not being filtered back to the
people if these companies are making
record profits why we're still paying
such high fuel costs laura
yeah so i think um the difficulty here
is the government doesn't want to commit
to what would be called a windfall tax
previous governments have done it and
this would be a one-off tax that's
focused on energy companies and those
particular profits that they're making
at the moment um clearly the tide is
shifting though on that isn't it even
with the chancellor now saying he's
looking at a pragmatic approach
potentially yeah it does seem like um
the weight of public opinion is shifting
it's i think it's a tricky one i think
um there are winners and and losers in
it and it's a fairly blunt tool to be
honest um
in
applying this kind of one-off tax
what we've also got to bear in mind is
lots of pension funds own those
companies and benefit from the dividends
they pay out and those pensions are held
by all of us and so any money that's
taken off those companies and paid in
tax is less money they can pay out to
investors which also impacts individuals
in terms of their pension fund so it's a
tricky balancing act but um yeah there
is a lot of weight opinion pushing the
government towards it oh we'll see what
happens on the windfall tax thank you
for now you're watching a special
question and answer program on sky news
tonight on the cost of living crisis
next we will ask what happened to the
job retention incentives for small
businesses during the pandemic after the
break
[Music]
hello welcome back to sky news tonight
you're watching a special question and
answer program on the cost of living
crisis families and businesses are
straining under a weight of global price
increases largely caused by demand
outstripping supply post pandemic and in
recent months the effects of course of
the war in ukraine well sky's ivor
bennett has been examining how global
forces may be eroding living standards
right here in the uk
the uk economy is flatlining this chart
shows gdp going back 15 years and you
can see we fall off the covid cliff and
then rapidly climb back up but the last
two months shows zero growth in february
and a contraction last month of 0.1
now the uk is not alone it's mid-table
in the g7 of major economies measured by
real gdp that's adjusted for inflation
and you can see we're growing slower
than the likes of the us canada and
france but faster than germany japan and
italy but here's the problem inflation
has soared in the last year reaching 7
in march and it's forecast by the bank
of england to exceed 10 percent by the
end of the year the main reason is the
energy crisis soaring gas and oil prices
have already increased domestic bills by
more than 50 percent and pushed up costs
across the entire economy and consumer
confidence is fragile we're no longer
hiding from covet but spending is
falling as fuel and food bills eat up a
larger proportion of our budgets and
then there's the war in ukraine russia's
invasion is not fully reflected in these
figures but it will increase pressure on
the energy market and hit grain and
cooking oil supplies around the world as
a result come the autumn household
energy bills may have increased by more
than a thousand pounds in a year
increasing pressure on the government to
act
tax cuts are being considered a one
percent cut to income tax would cost 5
billion pounds and be worth 175 pounds
to every taxpayer
but cutting income tax helps the better
off most and would come just months
after national insurance was increased
to fund the nhs
increasing benefit payments would target
the most in need they have gone up 3.1
percent raising that to 8 in line with
the expected inflation would cost 9
billion pounds for a year but it would
go straight into the pockets of those
struggling the most whatever he does the
chancellor says he's considering a
windfall tax on oil and gas company
profits to pay for it first proposed by
labour they say it would raise 2 billion
pounds but that only saves 60 pounds on
every bill
any help will be welcome of course but
will it but it will come at a cost to
the public finances the worst of kovid
may be behind us but the cost of living
squeeze has only just begun
either bennett there well let's answer
some more of your questions with our
expert panel in the studio tonight laura
suter head of personal finance at the
investment platform aj bell also nina
skera chief executive at the center for
economics and business research and sumi
rabindra kumar head of policy and
research at the trussell trust which
runs a network of food banks across the
country thank you for uh bearing with us
let's move on with our questions in the
last uh segments of our programme
tonight uh a question through instagram
does the government have a long-term
plan rather than just short-term
solutions laura we know this crisis is
going to go on for some time so one
would think
the government would have to look to the
long term here
you would hope so but at the moment it
feels like they are announcing and
releasing policy slightly more off the
hoof and reacting to the current crisis
so uh when we saw energy bills rise in
april ahead of that we saw an
announcement specifically about energy
bills we saw changes to the national
insurance increase that still brought
the increase in but adjusted it and made
the system very complicated to
understand but made it cheaper for some
people i think at the moment what we're
struggling to see is
that coherent long-term policy of this
is the support the government will
provide over the next year and instead
it feels like they're reacting more to
the current crisis on their plate and
how to deal with that and nina is it a
fact that the government may be waiting
till later in the year to see really how
bad the situation gets before deciding
on any long-term action
that is possible but the risk is that if
they wait too long the situation will
get even worse than it would have gotten
if they act sooner so i think there is
already enough evidence to suggest and
to show just how many households are
struggling
the economists are unanimous in saying
that inflation will stay elevated for
for longer um you have also economic
forecasters including um including the
bank of england expecting a recession so
i think there is already sufficient
evidence to suggest that it's time to
act now rather than put people through
further hardship before before something
is done all right talking of hardship
darren says i have a choice council tax
or electricity and gas and food it's not
hard to choose the winner um assuming
people are across the board having to
make choices aren't they
that's right and i think really what
this
example shows from darren is that it's
there's no there's no longer really
choices anymore these are just
impossible decisions about which
essentials they can cover it's not about
having a buffer where you can start
tightening your purse strings and and
decide what to you know where to
prioritize your your finances
what people are telling us when they
come to food banks is that there aren't
any further cutbacks to make they're
sort of out of options and also food
bank managers are telling us that they
also feel that they're out of options
too that people are doing or they can
you know that they're trying to ensure
that they're claiming everything that
they're eligible for
they're budgeting
um they're prioritizing you know
what
they're on their household spending um
but there's nothing there's nothing
really left to do to manage the cost of
living crisis at the moment
and actually it we do we have seen that
in our network for a number of years now
for some people but what's really
concerning is that this is obviously
accelerating
gathering speed and we know that things
are set to get worse as has been said um
this autumn and so really now's the time
for the government to step in and show
that they recognize the sort of
emergency that's really unfolding now
for many people in our communities
all right we'll come back to you very
shortly adam says on the 5th of november
2020 the government canceled the job
retention bonus a 1 000 pound incentive
to employers to retain staff and
continue topping up their furlough what
happened to the retention incentive that
failed to materialize the many thousands
of pounds employers are owed have a
massively detrimental effect on
businesses is there any intention adam
asks to repay
the debt uh nina let's put that one to
you
i certainly don't think there is any
intention of bringing that back and i
think the the chancellor has been quite
definitive in the way he has talked
about that the justification being that
that was cancelled because the furlough
scheme was extended now you could it's
certainly valid to ask questions about
is it uh is it reasonable is it fair to
make an announcement have businesses
make
business decisions on the back of that
announcement and then basically say that
the things aren't that things have
changed and that that assistance won't
be forthcoming i would say
in aggregate that the furlough scheme in
the uk was very generous and lasted for
quite a long time so hopefully most
businesses would have benefited that
needed at that time would have benefited
from the ability to keep staff on
furlough for longer and were were able
to get some form of assistance if not
that specific thousand pounds per per
employee coming back from furlough okay
final question we are a couple this is
through twitter earning a total of 35
000 pounds annually after tax we are
bringing up three children spending on
basics and still saving some for
holidays why can't other people start
acting
wisely a quick one for you laura that's
pretty unfair to many people that i
would many might suggest yes i think so
i think um but it probably echoes the
views of some people out there who think
well i'm doing fine prices have gone up
a little bit but i can still afford it
everyone else should just budget and i
think it just matters depends massively
on your circumstances um how you came
into this cost of living crisis whether
the pandemic impacted your finances
dramatically or not and so i think while
that person is doing very well um other
people are really struggling and it's
not just a case of cutting back on
netflix or shopping at a cheaper shop
and final word to you timmy in a quick
sentence when you hear that why can't
other people start acting wisely what do
you think
i think for some people they are
fortunate enough to have a buffer to um
choose you know to change their spending
decisions for people on the very lowest
incomes people that need to use food
banks um they don't have that option
they don't have the luxury of that
option
and that's why we need government action
to ensure that people are protected from
the very worst of the crisis that's
unfolding at the moment all right uh
sumi rabindra kumar nina scaro and laura
suter thank you very much indeed for
joining us on our special q a programme
today